hey I have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p you
can call anytime here's a voicemail i
received you know the right-wing pundits
to compare Donald Trump's joke to Joe
Biden's back in two thousand eight is
sad and it's very disingenuous don't
comment yesterday could possibly get
somebody to try to kill the Secretary of
State right Democratic nomination for
president yet so we could try to kill
her over those comments the way he made
them with that desperation in his voice
I was calling out to crazy people I
can't do it please help me that's all
that message said yesterday that was
very dangerous very scary and I cannot
believe the reaction that we're getting
from it it is Wow yeah had to be brought
up on charges so at a loss for words
will know we take our politics seriously
yeah not just did so uh a lot of people
that reaction Louis just that this is
absolutely unconscionable uh
stochastically speaking Trump may be
inciting someone to actually go and try
to kill Hillary Clinton that was the
consensus from many in our audience not
the Trump supporters although even some
of the Trump supporters email me saying
this is sort of the straw that broke the
camel's back on the bonus show today we
will talk about a fatal shooting that
happened during an acted scenario at a
Citizens Police Academy completely
unbelievable we will also talk about
Olympic ghost town and what happens
after the Olympics leave town and lastly
some snapchat filters draw criticism we
will discuss those and more on today's
bonus show of course sign up on the
brand new david pakman show website we
have one half price membership left with
coupon code beta 50b ETA 50 and you will
get instant access to the bonus show
when you sign up